beyond the grip of the familiar a
threshold demands to be crossed
the mortal shells yearn for meaning
awaiting a glimpse of their true purpose
these four lines are at the start of
mortal shell and they give us a fair bit
to think about as we play
the game's title mortal shell can also
be said as this a being that has the
possibility of experiencing death
who is also a shell of who they once
were and that makes a lot of sense
our character is called by many names
foundling unborn
aberration and an empty vessel a
foundling is described as a baby with
parents who left them at birth and given
to others to be taken care of
very similar to an orphan except as an
orphan that specifically means your
parents passed away
but this can be interpreted in a
different way we're without a background
the shells we awaken the npcs we meet
they all have backstories in history we
as the foundling just show up with
no real reason why a foundling while
being a person with no present guardian
in their life i feel within the context
of the game it's
a person with no ties to anyone a
foundling doesn't know their past
and why they are there or what created
them just like the character we play we
are just a person
without meaning looking for a purpose i
think what solidifies this
is the secret ending while a bit comical
in nature it's still something we should
question
within fog room there's an npc called
baghead a very similar looking to all
the brigands we see in the game except
this one isn't hostile to us
he doesn't do much other than ask if you
have rat and moonshine but after giving
him both items
he offers you a chance to be friends
forever and hang out a bit more
once accepted music plays while footage
of falgrim plays in the background
as a founding we don't have a purpose
yet as we haven't found one so who says
we can't sit
and relax for eternity with a friend by
our side drinking moonshine and eating
rats till the day we
die i understand this may be passed off
as a joke ending by the devs for comedic
relief so i propose an alternative one
of the biggest mysteries in this game is
the intro
we as the foundling awakens some other
plane of existence covered in water and
mist immediately after we are then
taught various things like hardening in
typical combat and then face off against
hader
a being who only appears in this plane
of existence and nowhere else
the only info we get on him is an
etching in the beginning of the game
which talks about hadron giving gifts to
the people
and how they were wasted on them as
these people are creatures now and are
twisted and malformed there's not a
whole lot of information on this hatter
and fella but i've come up with two
ideas
either hadern was a citizen of some high
standing and has since passed away
but before he did he passed on some
gifts to the people of fogrim
or he's a spiritual being who could be
considered a god and now has an agenda
he wants fulfilled which is where you
come in i'm going to go with the latter
on this idea as waking up in this plane
of existence fighting this person we
don't even know and then him sending us
off on our way is just
all really weird on top of this he's
also watching over us all the time
every time you leave this plane you
leave by being swallowed by a giant worm
fish
well this also happens at the end of the
game if you die to the unchained you
immediately start back at the beginning
of the fight and are given an option to
leave or not
if you do then the fish comes by and
swallows you the same exact fish that
allah swallows you up when hatter's
nearby pattern also forces us to fight
and defeat him before acquiring new
weapons almost like he's testing us and
once we meet his expectations
he knows we're ready for what lies ahead
regardless i think this is likely the
reason we are the way we are
something unexpected occurred thanks to
hatter maybe having some involvement
and because of this we aren't really
liked as we are normal
and don't fit the beliefs of the current
religions brother corvette of the seat
of infinity even scolds us when arriving
in our foundling form
saying that his fellow brothers hate us
because of the sins of our fathers it's
unclear specifically what he's talking
about but it does have to do with the
past generations of us
before we arrived and their actions
which likely caused them to hate us
and those actions are likely a result we
are seeing now because after being sent
from patterns place we arrive in falgrim
a dark decrepit swamp full of rotting
soldiers and warriors
but it wasn't always like this see
fogrum used to be a thriving kingdom
like most kingdoms it had a large
populace all with different social
classes
usually based on wealth all of which
contributed to the thriving of the
kingdom in some way
kingdoms also have religions regardless
of what religion you subscribe to
most contain a higher being considered a
god and in falgrim
gods are also named the revered there
are a few of these revered folk within
the game and we'll get to them shortly
but these revered left gifts called
nectar nectar is a fraction of the
revered transcendent nature basically
manifested into a physical form
these were seen as special since they
came from the revered themselves they
must be significant in some way this tar
was also found out to be very practical
the people at the seat of the infinity
would use nectar for their rituals and
the remains of this nectar which they
would usually discard were found out to
actually be really good for the lesser
devout as they would sell these off and
the lesser devout would use them for
healing wounds and relieving maladies
drinking this would transform people it
would make them feel closer to the
revered with every sip they took
but almost like it was a hallucination
and we would see these effects in full
thanks to teal
with the tar throbbing in my belly i see
her completely
each movement creates a swarm of copies
they ripple out from her following their
own whims
some collide and join together while
others split apart
forming new copies a reflection
of reflections spreading out from her
two
winters that is all the physician
promised was left for me the melody
gnaws at the corners of my eyes
prize the flesh from fingers and toes
it burrows deeper and deeper into my
bones
with each passing day teal was so
hell-bent on consuming tar
that after consuming enough these
maladies from drinking the tar decayed
his flesh and bone
making him unrecognizable to his kin in
an attempt to get help
he went to the seat of infinity where
upon arriving he was delirious
these people who were waiting for him
were the brothers and sisters of the
order
and we get to meet one of them at
faulgram tower sester ganesa
sister ganesa a woman we have never met
before already gave us a name and
helps us in our purposes she keeps our
flesh safe when we die so we can
reincarnate
and continue our journey but as we
stated before the brothers hated our
past generation so wouldn't the sesters
hate us too
as they're all part of the order well
maybe but let's come back to that
up the stairs at the tower is a
bird-like creature confined and
imprisoned held together by rubble and
chain as well as a tarnished seal that
was used to chain the prisoner in
tightly his name is the old prisoner
and he thanks you for helping him as no
one has attempted to help him for a very
long time
the old prisoner says that if you can
retrieve the glands of the revered that
this would be enough to heal him
when meeting him in the foundling form
he decides to share a little bit of a
secret with us
sester gonessa was your typical sister
serving the revered and yearning for
immortality
but she did it she is immortal her body
so to speak was shattered and
reconfigured but
now has made it to the other side she
got what she wanted to become immortal
except now she's cursed eternally to
observe and watch as the days go by
but she achieved her goal this is why
she can save us when we die and is in
every place in the game at one time
she's the immortal observer this is her
job i bring this up as this is extremely
important
these sisters and brothers and even the
lesser devout in the other areas of the
kingdom
all worship these revered not only to
become closer with them and feel
a more spiritual connection between them
and their revered god
but to also ascend from this world and
become immortal
when you die in mortal shell a quote
comes up that reads morse finis
which means death is not the end of life
but it's continuation
a call to life after death being reborn
and immortality
all themes that occur throughout the
whole game and that specifically is the
driving force for the old prisoner
the old prisoner saw visions of his
ascension which is why he needs the
sacred glands in order to ascend
it doesn't seem like this is the first
time he's tried this though as from the
inscriptions it states
the old prisoner sits contently atop his
perch awaiting the newest
the unborn must be greeted with gifts
but gifts they will bestow in return for
unwaving loyalty
another etching talks about the dark one
which as we know is another name for the
dark father
a name that the old prisoner is also
called it talks about how people have
moved into temples with tall monuments
built by devoted hands
that's why the way for him to ascend is
the only way
every group within the game believes in
some different revered god and has
different rituals
but since the old prisoner won't believe
these false truths he has to take
matters into his own hands and get the
glance for himself
this then gives the foundling a purpose
help the prisoner by retrieving the
glands and allow him to ascend
these glands are the knotted the
inflamed and the crystalline glands and
they can be found in the three areas of
the game
and are guarded by three individuals who
are the revered of their respective
locations
and the shrine of ash since emerald the
repentance hiding below the shifting
archives in the seat of infinity is
crux's the twice born
and deep within the bottom of the crypt
lying dormant is tarsus the first
martyr within the shrine of ash it's
clear this place has different
ideologies than the sasters and brothers
of the order
as in the inscriptions and etchings we
find within the area
there are talks of immolation as well as
hate towards the order claiming how they
seek a utopia which doesn't exist and
are charmed and distracted because of
the nectar they drink which as we know
is told to bring people closer to the
revered gods but also cause
hallucinations
the shrine of ash has three areas we can
explore the temple grounds the monument
of ash and the sanctum of flame this
place used to be a temple of sorts while
also housing a large forge used by many
who were handy enough to work it
such as the arc engineer and the
metallurgists acolytes and heralds of
all kinds fill the hall and they aren't
really keen to outsiders
you'll notice a running theme within
this game that every area has different
enemies
some do have similar looks and attacks
but are very different in their design
this proves that these people worship
the revered that sit within the areas
they reside
in this instance all the acolytes and
heralds of ash worship amrot the
repentant in the immolation ritual as he
is the revered of this location
these acolytes and heralds are described
to us by sister gnessa as gruesome
mostly just decaying flesh and bone
packed with sacred ashes
she also says how she doesn't miss the
impurities of flesh as
another hand she's immortal while also
explaining how she used to compare
herself to these acolytes within the
shrine of ash individuals who
just want to be one with their god just
as she wanted but hopes we don't become
like them and found amongst the bird ash
of the flame
these individuals of the shrine of ash
do a ritual called
immolation which is self-sacrifice and
they use the sanctum of the flame to do
so
a large pit filled with lava once used
by the forge masters
now used for sacrificial offerings and
spiritual connection upon drinking the
nectar we collapse and awake in a realm
home to imrod the area is covered in
sand dust and dead bodies it's clear who
these bodies are but they seem close to
some of the brigands of falgrim as well
as some of the acolytes of ignis judging
from the armor so either imrod is
killing those who are the outsiders of
the shrine of ash or he's purging the
weak individuals that perform the ritual
to become closer to him but to him are
unworthy he also uses the strength of
his flame abilities to burn other souls
for his own gain and then throws them
away like trash as he sees them as
unworthy we then receive the inflamed
gland and a glimpse of annihilation both
items containing warm temperatures
and feelings of anguish as screams can
be heard within the core of the glimpse
itself within the faces inside it more
and more looking like ash and smoke and
less like people this then leads to the
mysterious circumstance whenever the
foundling holds a sacred gland everyone
is on high alert and all the enemies
within falgrim are replaced with
noctisurpers who constantly hunt the
foundling
this is like with haddern another one of
these game mysteries with no explanation
these glands hold the most purest form
of true nectar if you want at the top of
the line in terms of tar and nectar
this is it which is why the people these
are bestowed upon are considered gods
they contain these glands within them
it's said that
each drop contains transcendence and
transfigurement which is existence
beyond the physical realm
and the ability to change one's
appearance respectively this is why we
go to new areas when sipping this nectar
we're transcending into different
physical planes of existence
sister ganesa can no longer help us with
the extraction of this gland
as it's basically above her ability to
handle those of pious hands or
blasphemous hands in our case can
achieve this ability of extraction like
the old prisoner
as he is the only one we can give these
glands to upon arriving we meet a new
person
festus he mentions how we brought the
fog with us he says this regardless if
we hold a gland or not so i'm assuming
this is tied to glimpses
this is what he summons the fog with and
gets rid of it
vestus also points out how we have
revered fluids talking about the gland
that we have with us but we aren't
anointed so
how did we get it he also states that we
stink of violence but
good riddance to those revered
individuals because they spread sickness
wherever they go
so he'd rather they rot away and die you
bring him glimpses and he will bring
back the fog
while this is more gameplay oriented
this does give us a bit more insight
into those creatures that come out
during the fog
according to thestus these creatures
don't hunt for coin or food they only
hunt for glimpses so they can feel that
raw emotion once more
thestus also indulges in this practice
of hunting glimpses for that raw emotion
as well i think it'd be a good time to
explain glimpses as they aren't really
explained too well but they come in a
variety of sizes and forms all with
different reasons for existing glimpses
in their most
basic form of explanation is a memory
the glimpse of wisdom bestows the owner
with
memories and lost insights while the
glimpse of affection fills the bearer
with warm passion but the biggest
question is how do these even exist if i
die right now will i drop a glimpse can
someone take my glimpses
can i give people my glimpses and if i
find a glimpse of wisdom for example
which shows the memories and insights of
someone
are these my old memories or the person
i took them from
memories these will have to remain
unanswered as there isn't enough
evidence to come up with an indisputable
answer
but there is a theory that i do propose
to this i think glimpses come in all
shapes and sizes with all different
functions but when you find these
glimpses they relate to you
let me elaborate finding a glimpse of
wisdom will show you your memories and
insights as it now pertains to you
why would the noctiserpers seek these
glimpses these creatures are completely
deformed humans unrecognizable and more
savage in nature
it's unsure what caused this but it
might be obvious to speculate that
nectar had something to do with this
regardless they aren't human anymore
completely changed
so they would want these glimpses to
relive these memories and warm feelings
they felt when they were alive so to
speak
this is the only explanation that i can
come up with at the moment and hopefully
it's pretty close to the right idea
i've never been a big fan of adding
theory to a lore video where it should
be all facts and explanation but
sometimes things aren't explained so
theorizing is the only solution
the only thing left to do to progress
once you have the gland though is to
bring it to the old prisoner he talks
about how the glands are vessels
of the divine and how the devotee only
wastes them by not using its fullest
potential he also instructs us to visit
the two remaining locations one of these
two
is the crypt of martyr this is where the
dead are left to rot and stay imprisoned
within the catacombs
the enemies within the catacomb ended up
dragging a grisha down into the depths
and are considered a slave and a
guardian forced to sit in an ice cavern
enshrined in ice as the disciples pray
but he is also considered a guardian
like i said but he's guarding the
immaculate as the shrine of ash was
about sacrificing oneself to be closer
to the god they pray to
the crypt and its followers guard the
immaculate with their life
waiting for the ascension of everyone
who is enshrined within the ice and the
immaculate herself to rise
only then will they discover the true
spiritual connection you must kneel
before the immaculate and place your
palm on the deathless doctrine provided
then surrender your pride vanity and
will
this allows the immaculate to guide you
with her eternal wisdom
untouched and unspoiled your spirit will
not falter if it is hers to command
a note written by someone enshrined in
ice now states that their first
vision was like a dream this person was
in a vast chamber where he found himself
a
maiden crowned winter glass she placed
her hands around his throat and sent him
back to reality
but the icy presence still remained
linking the two forever this is most
likely a man
talking about his experience with the
immaculate for the first time
but people doubted the religion and its
beliefs which led to the first martyr
tarsus the first martyr didn't give up
his blood or body
he gave up his own living memory sealed
within the ice to preserve the faith of
the immaculate while the immaculate is
the leader of this religious group
it's the martyr who sacrificed himself
so that others can prosper which is why
he's constantly revered
by the people within the crypt eredrim
also signed his name with the deathless
doctrine
he wanted to be enshrined along with
others because arrogant was tired of war
and
almost scarred by it and wanted to
believe in something that could stop it
the overt made promises
of an end to war and human suffering
promises all were desperate to hear
myself not least for i'd seen my share
of tragedy
i scratched my name in their book
swearing myself to the deathless
doctrine
they say that beyond the ice
the old world is preserved
no war no famine
no suffering eternal peace
shielded by their unwavering
sovereignty and lineage that spans
centuries why should i not be
counted among the privileged
eardrum also constantly talks about how
the weak and unwilling should not be
enshrined as they don't deserve it and
that he has proved himself
worthy sacred rights remain closed to me
i'm unworthy of the venerated nectar
but i will prove myself
these sniveling rats who bow and scrape
will never be enshrined
they have neither the will nor the
strength
to accept the deathless doctrine
as stated before though the beginning of
the crypt contains the dead and unwanted
with the occasional enslaved disciple
there to pray and watch over the
guardian
but the crypt goes deeper as we know it
leads to a sanctum in a large altar room
where we meet more people who are
waiting for the ascension of the
immaculate
the sanctum used to be a large place of
worship until all the faithful had left
the hall had
tons of banquets and feasts in honor of
their forefather but he grew distant and
eventually became
unwelcome so now the visitors are
greeted with suspicion and scorn
like we receive but guarding the
immaculate as we know
is the first martyr he sits inside her
defending her
this altar is resonating with the
immaculate's presence her eternal winter
she possesses preserves the martyr so
that they can serve
even in death the flesh of the martyrs
is put into scriptures of sacred text
and pass around the faithful followers
just like the last time you sip the
nectar and fight the being on the other
side
this being the first martyr tarsus upon
killing tarsus you rip out the gland
from his body and are given a glimpse of
insignificance in the crystalline gland
a cold-looking gland showing nothing but
cold bright light said to make the bear
remember past
enthusiastic memories the glimpse is a
confusing one though however
no matter how long someone searches into
the glimpse they never find their
reflection on the surface
since glimpses are looking at memories
this could be interpreted as the future
is uncertain
so it can't exactly display what hasn't
happened or isn't 100
possible to happen as it's the future
but the past that's already
been made these things happen and things
didn't happen so showing the past is
easy
and that's what glimpses do showing the
future isn't as easy
as anything can change the future taking
this back to the old prisoner we now
have
the only place left the seat of infinity
the seat of infinity is where the
brothers and sisters of the order reside
probably the weirdest place of the three
wherein the other two have actual
structures with supports and some
natural elements flowing in with them
this place is large open and floating in
some parts
on a secret path to the area itself
underneath the stairs
is a corrupted sester represented by
wearing a red mask
going off the fact that she is named
corrupted sester and is wearing a red
mask to signify that
i'm assuming this was intentional and
she was outcasted by the order
her inventory has some forbidden
merchandise forbidden offerings
effigies and tainted nectar and i would
like to take more time with the
forbidden offering since this is the
only one in the game you only need one
of these items to complete the upgrade
and she's the only one that has it the
forbidden offering says quotes a
perverse offering to the tarnished seals
the rite of transfiguration remains
forbidden but its practice is not
completely forgotten
the promise of revelation carried a high
price for those who glimpsed the
unknowable
such followers became forsaken creatures
fit only to be locked away
my theory is since she is carrying this
offering meaning she attempted to
complete a ritual or had already
completed one
and once the other members the order
caught wind of it she was exiled out and
left to fend for herself
a sister without any powers who was just
exiled out cannot defend herself against
the creatures of falgren so she chose to
hide under the seat of infinity stairs
as to be safe and hopefully not caught
by the others as not too far from the
area there is a group of brigands with
swords and crossbows
many come here to the seat of infinity
looking for answers but will find
nothing but silence
to be reborn a child of the many a
sister or brother in this case
you must throw yourself into the chasm
and let the void beneath take and remake
you those of which
who do become the sisters and brothers
but they are emptied
no longer remembering their name just to
be reported into some human-like vessel
not confined to shape or time they are a
being within a body but
time doesn't end when the body does
their spirit continues to move on
the seat of infinity and their order is
a strange one using nectar in their
rituals and having members drink it
until they're mad
but that doesn't seem to bother them as
a nectar is the one way to feel
connected with their god
many of the scholars within the order
went mad writing all kinds of gibberish
within the books of the shifting
archives thanks to this
sister ganesa talks about how we may
regret trespassing here not only because
of her fellow sisters and brothers
but their twins this might be a
reference to the plethora of armed
guards in this place
we know that the brothers and sisters
look a lot like your typical priest or
scholar with some slight modifications
thanks to us being able to see the
models of sester ganesa
her corrupted sister and brother corvid
they seem like typical religious figures
the others don't the sublime sester
sester of the order
brother of sanad sublime brother and the
faceless cleric
don't seem like typical religious
figures in fact the sublime brother is
very close to the blazing herald and the
brother of sanada being close to the
acolyte of ignis which are warriors
within the shrines of ash
now the way that the map operates in
this game the shrine of ash is near the
seat of infinity so it may not be
far-fetched to assume that maybe some
have crossed over and joined different
religious groups based on beliefs but i
want to go back to that mirror and twin
statement gnsm made her statement says
just as every flame casts a shadow
so too does the spirit and here they
manifest
this talks about how even in light
darkness still remains
no one is truly good in the world so i
think these armed guards with their dark
nature
is a manifestation of the dark side of
the order to put it simply you have your
lights which is your typical members of
the order but within every member is a
dark past or obsession
and in here that manifests into physical
people these guards within the seat of
infinity nothing is certain this is
obvious by the crumbling world that we
see throughout the place
and the members here don't mind these
inconsistencies of the world but more
embrace them as a curious blessing from
the revered and
they also mention how they worship those
who are twisted and reborn
the shifting archives within the seed of
infinity is a large library filled with
tons of written scripture
theory and ideologies members sit here
and would try to catalog the contents of
the library but
it was found unsuccessful these members
would search for a revelation even as
they are surrounded by madness the
sacred tablets once looked upon by the
scholars now collect dust
individuals blinded by the unfathomable
knowledge would be able to inscribe its
mysteries with hammer and chisel
these servants still remain but have no
more insight anymore
as they are now just faceless guardians
leaving the library unattended
and unused all that's left is twice born
crucifix
the twice born unlike other revered
beings requires no pledges
the reward for loyalty is enslavement
which may describe the committed
devotion these members have
the toys born drops the glimpse of
oblivion and the knotted gland from his
body
the bearer of the glimpse is filled with
a sense of emptiness their surroundings
turn into a muted joyless world their
mind slows and their limbs grow heavy
while the not a gland is a gland that
beats irregularly almost as if there
were two hearts in it this is the final
gland we need we rip
out the gland out of the head's tongue
almost as if the head was the
spirit or soul of the toy sport taking
it back to the old prisoner he calls us
naive going through all this hardship
for one person when only he will ascend
not us and says that we should be
honored to be able to see the ascension
of another being
the old prisoner says that we are just
an empty shell with only instinct and
flesh
left without purpose led by false idols
and that if even for an instant he will
let us bask in the truth and to witness
his ascension
furthermore he rambles on how this is
what it must feel like to be picked
among the many to rule over the lesser
souls
how fate favors those who act and not
those who sit there with no purpose
and that the maggots of this place bow
and scrape before their gods while their
lives unravel thread by thread
in a pile of utter meaninglessness with
the sacred glands in hand he leaves and
goes down the hole
when we follow him we get to see his
true form but there's a problem
everything was wrong he had visions of
ascending into a new life
but now it's all just darkness and
shallow water these visions weren't of
him
but of us and our ascension he's
questioning why we should be allowed to
leave but the rest remain stuck
in falgrim calling this unjust now his
goals have changed
now that he can't descend he won't let
anyone else ascend
sester ganesa brings up to us that when
we take the twice boring land how
us taking these glands was almost like
we were destined to almost as if it was
fate
and then also tells us to not
overindulge she mentions how a heretic
she once knew
was greedy and drank too much of the
true nectar that didn't belong to him
and how he turned into a different being
entirely very different from a human
and how that this was his reward for his
greediness i can't help but wonder if
this person she mentions is the old
prisoner the old prisoner has always
seemed very greedy constantly wanting
everything and for everything to go his
way and when it doesn't he gets other
people to do his bidding for him
the old prisoner stated to us before
that he also once knew sister ganesa
this story of a man she once knew
becoming too greedy and turning into a
beast could very well be the old
prisoner and what we see
is that beast he turned into upon his
defeat as the foundling
we retrieve and extract the dark
father's gland this gland allows the
player to ascend
upon accepting the foundling throws the
gland and basks in the true nectar
removing his shell
and leaving the mortal plane once the
credits roll we are back at the tower
sester ganesa welcomes us with her usual
greeting except something's off
we ascended yet why are we back in the
tower
that's the burden of immortality just
like her being able to live on forever
she is cursed to observe and watch every
day of her life whereas we get to live
on forever as well
except we continue to do what we were
already doing forever or as she put it
toil without end but she says not to
worry as there is some comfort and
even some pleasure in ritual then
continues to go back to her normal self
and
offers us a sip this is the ending of
mortal shell
ascending past the mortal plane being
reborn and becoming immortal like sister
ganesa
but also like her bound to stay and
struggle without end
as our spirit is separated by the
profane eternities that exist
giving us one foot in the other world
beyond the mortal plane
but not fully removed from the plane
from whence we came as that is the curse
of immortality
our body like sester ganesa is just a
vessel now where as we stated when
discussing the order
our spirit will live on past the age of
our body as now we are just immortal
the body is just a vessel for us to pour
ourselves into
and use until we see fit kind of like
how we've been using the shells
throughout our journey
bodies we inhabit until we discard them
in replace of another or to show our
true form
that's the ending of mortal shell before
we head out though i know this is a lot
of information so i wanted to summarize
what we've gone through
it won't be as detailed but if you want
to get the absolute bare minimum
understanding of what's going on with
the game then
here it is we as the foundling someone
with no purpose at the moment of our
arrival
meet a prisoner who gives us that
purpose he asks us for a favor which is
to help us retrieve these sacred glands
so that they can heal him you as the
foundling go to three
areas the shrine of ash the crypt of
martyr and the seed of infinity
battling your way through to meet the
end bosses who possess the sacred glands
these are the founders of each of the
group's religious beliefs in all the
areas everyone has some sort of
religious belief
but they're all different and each god
they believe in is also different with
the end goal of having some sort of
spiritual connection with their god
in whatever way they believe the shrine
of ash whose god is imrad believes in
self-sacrifice by fire to feel a
stronger bond between them and the god
the crypt of martyr worshipers enshrine
themselves in ice so that they can be
reborn when the god
the immaculate arrives and the seed of
infinity houses the brothers ancestors
of the order who use
tar a substance said to be part of the
gods and their rituals they also end up
consuming the targ which caused them to
see visions of their god and making them
feel a stronger bond between the two
once collecting all of them the old
prisoner uses them to try to ascend
himself but finds out that the visions
he have been seeing aren't
of his ascension but you the players
with this knowledge in hand he is angry
and attempts to kill you once the player
defeats him they themselves can ascend
but as we have discovered
immortality isn't all that nice if
anything it's just a curse
that is mortal shell
now we get to the outro of sorts a time
where i don't have to ramble about
lore ideologies in theory a more
carefree section of the video let me
know how you enjoyed the mortal shell
story
it's definitely a complicated one filled
with subtext red herrings that were hard
to dig through but
in the end i think i came up with a
decent explanation on the game for those
who are wondering if you choose not to
ascend you actually get sent back to the
tower
like nothing ever happened if you do go
back into the hole the unchained
is alive again as we technically didn't
kill him by grabbing his gland so he is
still alive a very truly unexpected and
terrifying experience
stay tuned in the future as i plan to
cover the stories of the shells within
the game next as they are just as rich
in story as the game itself
and need to be shared thank you for
joining me on this journey if you like
the commentary like the video subscribe
for future videos coming soon
and goodbye
[Music]
you